je soussigné et vecteur legs
l'intégralité de mes parents ma fille
zoé tanner et combien elles valent tout
sépare nous devons aussi vous a signé un
nouvel agent de protection rapprochée et
je suis censé savoir qui vous êtes
sommes enchantés
on a constaté une nette augmentation des
cas de séquestration dans cette zone
vous êtes super fun
procédez comme convenu ne parler à
personne d'autre alors je dois partir
seul
ou est-ce que vous nous emmenez
dépêche toi d'abord on va mettre une
chose au clair je ne travaille plus pour
toi alors à partir de maintenant tu fais
ce que je te dis dans mon travail
terminé alors qu'est ce que tu fous là
est la personne d'autre
il faut que tu te débat tu bats toi te
laisse pas faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec
un peu plus
les amis sont censés pouvoir se faire
confiance
[Musique]
chrome et loire
je te le promets